i wanna uh lydia pulled up this uh this
graphic yeah this is an image that we've
seen before on the show and we debated
uh whether or not it was true and
correct but it's the ten stages of
genocide now the first thing is that
this graphic we have is an
oversimplification of the actual ten
stages of genocide
that was initially written i think it
wasn't written by a historian or
academic talking about what we see
through various authoritarian
dictatorships but let me just read some
for you
they say the first stage is
classification people are divided into
us and them
to stage two is symbolization people are
forced to identify themselves three
discrimination people begin to face
systematic discrimination four is
dehumanization people equated with
animals vermin or diseases
five is organization the government
creates specific groups police and
military to enforce the policies six is
polarization the government broadcasts
propaganda to turn the populace against
the group seven is preparation official
action to remove and relocate people
eight is persecution the beginning of
murders theft of property trial
massacres nine is extermination
wholesale elimination of the group and
ten is denial the government denies that
it committed any crime now
i don't think that this is a linear uh
path you know i think it's just
several things you see in uh genocide or
or uh you know uh dictatorship so i'll
just very quickly say
when the last time we talked about this
we we got to uh number two people are
forced to identify themselves and it's
like where are people being forced to
identify themselves yeah not australian
political political uh or uh
gender you know
pronouns on uncover you're not being
forced you're not being forced
i think we're on step seven mm-hmm right
the other coveted passports is kind of
let me identify yourself are you so
let's let's let's talk about the virus
so so the the the conversation we're
having before was about you know the
obviously you know january 6 they put
out this list of of a bunch of people
including trump activists but when you
think about it in terms of the vaccine
oh this list is
is scary i mean for one us and them oh
yeah they keep going on tv saying that
all of this is the fault of the people
who are unvaccinated people are forced
to identify themselves yes they're
mandating that you reveal your
identification at buildings people are
facing systematic discrimination you
can't go into buildings people are
acquainted with equated with animals
vermin or diseases horse medicine
they're talking about people who are
taking ivermectin not fda approved for
for use in covet mind you but they're
equating it with with animal the
government creates specific groups
police and military to enforce the
policies are we there yet is that
happening is there a specific group
that's been created for this
well the capital police has been
expanded but that's that's more maga
stuff that's not vaccine-related stuff
they say the government broadcasts
propaganda why i mean fouchy won't shut
up and then official action to remove
and relocate people i'll tell you this i
don't think we're there yet in terms of
the vaccine but you have various aspects
of this across the board we got to be
careful we don't play into this either
because the first one us and them i've
noticed when i have conversations here
and in general i talk about them like
they are the biden crew or whatever the
deep state whatever they i'm feeding
this and if i keep talking lazily acting
like that they're gonna keep acting like
see i just did it again they
there's no they it's us we are humans on
earth together ian that's that's that's
that's utopian well but if it's if we
don't go that direction we're going to
start dividing people's that's like
saying
it's very easy to lead someone who's
thinking in that those terms they you
know that you know and you hear this if
by the way what you just said is if you
turn on tune into msnbc or cnn right now
and you listen to how they talk about
these medical mandates they always use
terms of we and us we need to do this we
need to do that right we this is it's
always we it's always we need to make
things harder for them they've said that
and who is we and look at the way they
talk about where were you what was the
what was the adjective we kept using in
alaska when they talked about the crowd
who was at obama's birthday party how
they described sophisticated we are
sophisticated we're a sophisticated
vaccinated class right that's why there
was no concern about that party it was a
sophistic we are
the enlightened ones we're the smart
ones we are you you know bill maher made
this uh
five
six well maybe it was about a year and a
half ago one one has monologues we
talked about middle america right we
have
wolfgang puck they have chef boyardee
right right we have this they have that
they're envious of us so i i appreciate
what you're saying from the humanitarian
perspective i wish we were a we
but i fear that if i don't have a they
versus us
they're gonna kill me like they talk
about me
you know what they're doing to you with
this with this uh january 6 commission
right now
they have
complete desire to eradicate me from the
political space from the the discourse
space from the what i do for a living
and so if i don't put up boundaries
they're coming out and remember what
we've also seen that's going on and this
is something where that i'm going to get
into if they want to pursue this with me
is
they will set up operations and we've
seen this in the past we've seen this
even just last year
where the federal government and the fbi
will use a system of informants and
plants that will go into various groups
these sort of like edge case groups
discord chats facebook groups and then
they will become accelerants so they
will accelerate what's going on they'll
become accelerationists for that particu
that specific unit that specific group
of people whether it's a militia or
something and we are going to get onto
all of that nancy pelosi i want to find
nancy pelosi's personal communications
that were members of these militias i
want to go after all the communications
that her and her staff have had with
stewart rhodes and the oath
i want to make a pointer at what ian
said
the there's only one thing you need to
understand to understand uh so you know
that this this is just not correct go
tell the taliban what you just said go
walk up to them outside of the the
airport in kabul and say we're all in
this together there's no us in them and
see how they treat you well sometimes it
works no i've been in situations where i
don't even speak the language but as
long as you
vibe with them you are one of them
you're gonna vibe with the taliban i
don't know you could they're walking
around with guns they're they're they're
beating people in the streets that's
kind of a fantasy because i don't know
them i've never seen a person that
identifies as taliban or all i've seen
is propaganda i've i've met taliban i
think going to what you're saying their
their vibe is how much of the quran do
you have memorized their their vibe is
you know do you perform zakat are you
praying five times a day um and you're
an american it doesn't matter
i like the quran though
have you submitted to islam right it it
right yes and no but it it it doesn't
matter and if you're an american right
now then you're immediate like like yeah
well there are situations like this
practice some russian if you're over
their situation why did they beat that
right that australian guy there's an
australian guy just mind walking to the
airport and they just started beating
him why would they do that i don't know
it's just us right i see partly what
you're saying because there are
situations where it can become so
volatile that if you insert yourself
you'll be destroyed without in a moment
but what do you think is happening we
can also create that volatility
this is part of that creating that
volatility if we we can also create that
volatility if we want so it's like
you can acknowledge that it's there
without propelling it ignoring the
problem won't make it no i'm not saying
to ignore it i'm just saying i'll put it
this way as as you know as a as a
catholic i i believe that you know that
there is a heaven and in in that
wonderful you know the new eden the new
kingdom that there it will be us and we
will all be one and we'll all be
together but uh in this current moment
in this part of the movie that we're in
right now in what we're living through
what i'm personally living through when
i look at my kids when i put them to bed
and think is this the last time i'm
going to see them because somebody's
going to come knock on my door and take
me away with cnn getting because with
cnn getting tipped off because of my
opinions
right
i don't really have that luxury right
now
but i do have i do have my rosary and i
say that every day that's all i got you
raised an interesting point i think this
is where our system is rigged and it is
very messed up and that you said i'd
love to see nancy pelosi's
correspondence but but congress is
exempt
right congress doesn't have to share
their records no one has the authority
to ask for nancy pelosi's records now
she has the authority to ask for the
president's records um i find that
a huge flaw with our problem right foia
does not exist in the judicial and the
uh excuse me in the legislative branch
you can't ask your your senator i'll get
this man i'll get him well if someone
leaks them i'll get him but but my point
is that you don't have the the she has
she doesn't she doesn't know how far my
network goes
that's not what i'm saying i'm saying
that that legally she has
you don't right we don't and not
everyone is jack pasobi but daniel these
are better men that's not what they're
so sophisticated yeah they are
sophisticated they're so sophisticated
they're so much better that is a huge
problem with the way with the way things
are structured right now um and and so
you can subpoena
you you can impeach the president twice
but what authority does the president
have to say i would like to know how
nancy pelosi is coordinating with x y or
z to come after me in my administration
i want to see another one on the belt
fed uh the crew served a machine oh and
another one by the way chuck schumer did
did you see what happened to your boy
andrew
your boy andrew cuomo he's not really
smart boy he's actually saying that
because i'm from new york chuck you saw
that right by the way right
yeah
i know some things andrew or i know some
things chuck don't don't go there don't
go there
they're going there
okay chuck you know you know what's
funny is when you look over in australia
we got uh okay they're building camps
you know what i saw what's really funny
check this out check this out um they
have the qr codes as well on the doors
yeah yeah yeah they're putting they're
they're putting signs on people's doors
suspected of having coveted now he's the
best so you have to swipe in it's it's
gross it's grocery stores it's it's
where you when you go to work if you're
going uh i don't know if churches are
open this and now i think this is mainly
the new south wales it's that one
area where it's where it's working it's
it is it is uh
it's a minority report man
unit i saw today i looked at this
article from nine news australia of they
have an interactive map of all of the
areas of new south wales that are under
lockdown surprise surprise it's all of
them
and stay-at-home orders you're only
allowed to leave for very specific
things but chris hemsworth we're not
surfing you know why because if you're
rich you're exempt wow
absolutely and there's been people
complaining about it saying how come the
rich people are at the beach and they
said shut your mouth peasant do you
think anyone's going to arrest crimson
chris hemsworth he's a national icon
he's a treasurer
he's exempted just like our politicians
are exempt from
all of our code
i want to make sure this is clear i i
think chris hemsworth's red i don't
blame him for this good enough the
government everyone is is is is
implementing i'll put it this way i
don't think it's the fault of chris
hemsworth that he's successful unable to
go to the beach nope i think what that
really means is the government is
purposefully punishing the poor
they are purposefully beating down poor
people yeah that's the problem when did
you see the churches that they were
going after no you know i saw this video
and uh it's it's amazing because i
looked up the anchor's name because the
guy tweeted out it was some like a local
news thing in australia and the guy's
name was actually peter overton
his name is actually overton wow
simulation right and
and there and then they go and they
interview somebody and he said and it's
this it's this like you know pasty white
guy with a mask going well i just i just
had to call the police on this church
and what they were doing was just so
wrong and it was terrible it's like the
vocal fry you know and
and you and you look at the church and
these are like um
the majority of them appear to be
immigrants uh to australia and
they
very not well all i mean it's like
folding chairs and like not well off
church but it was a place where people
were going because they were looking for
some semblance
of connection to the eternal and to the
infinite something positive a sense of
community where they could get over and
because of one and you should hear the
way i don't know if you have the you
know the clipper of it but the way
they're talking about this church they
called them arrogant and they called
them greedy and self-interested and i'm
like these are these are christians
you're referring to this way people who
are not affluent people who aren't on
fancy news networks like peter overton
you you raised a great point of of how
you know it is punishing the poor and
when obama had his birthday party a
couple weeks ago and people were saying
you know hypocrisy etc i took a very
different approach and another thing
that happened at the birthday party john
kerry showed up in his private jet right
and people said shame on john kerry
hypocrisy and i said if i had john
kerry's wealth and married a
rich widow that's the old-fashioned way
you make your money right i would fly a
private jet and if i had obama's wealth
and prestige i would have a party with
600 of my closest friends the point is
not that they did it everyone should
have that right the point is that the
people telling us to go green and to
lock down are never going to do it right
they are never going to follow the laws
that they want the powerless the
voiceless the nameless and faceless keep
in mind is the problem what they're
doing now hypocrisy it's that you don't
have the power to thwart the laws that
the rest of us are imposing on what the
green movement has wanted for a
generation
the same people are now getting through
the threat of covet covet envy is a real
thing right so they they wish that they
could get right you know so now it's all
the people who were you know like sort
of like the grifter class the ones that
are just pushing this stuff they you
know they used to be climatologists now
they're all epidemiologists you know
they
went to bed one night and woke up and
now they're they're getting the
restrictions they are getting the
mandates they're getting everything they
wanted to take away people's liberties
and people's freedoms through the threat
of it's you know it's it's almost
cliched to say it at this point but the
rahm emanuel's famous quote never let a
crisis go to waste yeah and covid is for
your good for the good of society
therefore you have to follow these
prescriptions and the environmentalists
have wanted that forever that kovid shut
down people's ability to go to church
right the australia laws which are that
list that you mentioned which came out
today was
you read that and it it reads like uh uh
nazis nazis they're nazis man
people of
australia i mean they're protesting they
are but you have and it's going to get
literal
when i say literal i'm saying thousand
dollar fines if they catch you outside
if you're currently at what point do the
police the australian police who i hope
are listening to this podcast on
horseback say i am not going to hit this
person with my butt but you see the
video well did you see the hitting the
truckers videos at what point did the
australian police say i am not obeying
this order i saw you know and it was i
saw a couple of videos where it was
truckers saying you know we we run this
country and people realize so you look
on the map australia is pretty big but
it's if you look at the actual um you
know i always do map breaks on on
twitter if you look at the actual
populated areas it's only around the
coast right it's very sparsely populated
and so
those truckers that are absolutely
necessary as much as they are everywhere
else but really in australia when
they're shipping those goods when
they're shipping that food and you
you're starting now to hear these
truckers and they say they're saying we
will shut this country down over this if
you keep pushing us over this but will
enough we will stop that's the question
isn't it thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast irl podcast if
you want to see the full show come back
to this channel youtube.com tim cast irl
monday through friday at 8 pm where you
can leave comments and super chat and we
actually will read your comments on the
show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else go to timcast.com
become a member and we even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time
you